Hey traders, it's Mike from Orderflows
here. And you know, it's been a while
since I made a video, but I wanted to
sort of talk about this this uh these
markets. You know, they've been going uh
bonkers for since the beginning of the
year basically. And you know, with VIX
spiking up today, we're up uh around 20
just we hit 23 in the VIX, which is
quite high. We're seeing big sell-offs
across the board. Dow's down, NASDAQ's
down, E- Mini's down. Obviously, uh
Bitcoin is is unraveling. Um today we
think we've got Micro Strategies
earnings out and and their stock is
falling like a rock as well. Currency
markets are whipping around. Um but you
know the one thing that I want to
[clears throat] for me at least is uh
you know how orderflow trading can help
you as a trader understand what's going
on in the market. Now you know silver
has been on a big tear you know for the
last few months. Same with gold. And
it's a bit uh difficult to read the
order flow because it's a lot of zeros
right the market's looking for
liquidity. there's not a lot of
liquidity even though the moves are
fantastic and you know the there's
[clears throat]
traders are are making money but there's
still a lot of traders losing money just
due to the inherent volatility and when
volatility picks up in the markets you
know I I tell traders go to markets that
are more stable and what do I mean by
stable that aren't going to whip around
I mean for example I just showed you the
e- um the silver but even the e- minis
you know we're getting big moves this is
mees actually on a on a one minute chart
but you can see some of these bars that
go from 6804 all the way up to 6816. You
know, that's a uh a 12point move in one
minute. So, [clears throat]
what I tell traders to do rather than
try and fight the order flow because,
you know, volumes are thin, what's
happening in the market when VIX is high
is even though there's volume, but it's
really spread out over a wider area. And
as VIX goes up, so you know, your risk
goes up as well because now um the
swings are bigger, the rotations are
wider, and your existing stop levels
that you had from earlier are sort of
blown out of the water. So I I suggest
to traders, you know, when these markets
are really going um bonkers, so to
speak, because the VIX is high, I mean,
the VIX is a good level, a good measure
of that. You know, there's other markets
that you can trade that I don't want to
say are more stable, but don't have that
whippiness
that you see in markets that, you know,
trade less volume. Um, because the
market is looking for volume to trade.
That's why you're getting very wide
price swings. You know, a market like 10
years, which is a extremely liquid
market, meaning there's, you know,
thousands of contracts on the bid and
the offer and even in the book at each
price level. So you know the market will
move a little bit further than normal
but still it's it's kind of contained
right in the sense it's it's not wild
where it's going to go you know move
very quickly in
very wide uh price range okay but the
order flow analysis is still the same
okay and even on these thick markets
there's certain patterns in the order
flow that I like to look for okay you So
remember this is 10 years right a very
liquid market with strong bids and
offers thousands of contracts on the bid
thousands on the offer and at each price
level above and below. So if I see very
thin volume transacting in a bar at a
price level to me that's an area of
interest. Okay. So for example this
morning um in this bar right here right
you see the eight contracts. Okay, I
know that's significant because this bar
traded 52,000 contracts and when the
market was, you know, it was trading 26
and a half 27. Okay, and then it went 27
bid at 27 and a half, right? But only
eight contracts traded here when it was
in the bid offer at 7 and 12. Okay. So I
I know that this market is moving fast
in the sense that it went from 6 and 1/2
7 to 7 7 and 1/2 and then 7 1/28 right
and look it didn't in the next bar it
didn't even test that level at 27. So to
me, this is a significant level. I could
draw a line from this and see what
happens when the market comes back. You
know, it'll probably test this. Even
though it traded only eight contracts, I
sort of treat it as a interbar gap, so
to speak. Okay? And you can see how
[clears throat] the market went up, came
all the way back down, filled that
little gap, so to speak, right here.
Traded one tick through before running
back up. And you know another thing that
I also find very um
interesting is again you know this
market trades
tens of thousands potentially at a level
right you can see some of these volumes
14,000 18,000 10,000 11,000 you know
5,000 right so it's got strong volumes
and to see a imbalances in this market
tells me you know directional trade is
pretty strong. So you can see on this
rally up, what do you see? Just buying
imbalance, buying and balance, buying,
buying, buying imbalances all the way
up. You get this little bit of a turn
right here,
then you start seeing the selling
imbalances come in after you make this
high. So now, you know, maybe people
taking profits. Um, they're getting out.
As you see, the market pause a little
bit. You see some aggressive selling
come in here. Right after we hit this
high, it looked like this market was
about to start selling off again. Okay,
this high at uh 31 11131, you know, it
traded four. You got a nice exhaustion
print up here. Then you got aggressive
selling, aggressive selling. Even in
this bar, aggressive selling, aggressive
selling. [snorts] And the market really
looked like it was going to potentially
turn off. I mean, the deltas are
negative. You know, 6,000 negative 5,000
5,500US 10,000.
Okay. And then it changed in this bar.
What changed in this bar? Well, we got a
strong bid coming in here. 13,000. Okay.
Acting as support followed by a stack
buying a balance of four price levels in
this bar. This is a four range chart. So
there's five price levels. So while
there was some aggressive selling coming
in here and it did look bearish. I'll be
honest. It looked bearish. Looked like
it was about to sell off. The fact that
it sort of stuck around here and found a
support level again where at that area
where you had the aggressive buying
earlier, right? Because remember this
eight
signifies to me that you know there
there's
traders coming in here. They're not
interested in trying to, you know, sell
into this bid, whatever. They just
immediately took it seven when it was
seven bid, 7 1/2, immediately took it 7
1/2 bid
now that it's coming back around to that
area. There's still now I see support
coming in here. So, it's support coming
in followed by what? Stack buying a
balance. So I know there's aggressive
buying, you know, and again this is
coming in right after we see that these
two red bars here with the selling
imbalances 1309 7245 7966 15,000. Okay?
Cuz again, you know, that's bearish.
That's how flow works. It can change
instantly. As a trader, you need to be
able to pick up that the order flow has
changed. You can't be sitting here
saying, "Oh, you know what? This is
bearish because I got all these selling
imbalances. I'm going to be short and
ignore the aggressive buying that's
coming in. Again, very similar. You
know, here you had eight contracts. Now
you just got 2960s. Very thin volume.
This bar trades 11,000. Can only trade
29 contracts at 29 a.5 60 at 30. Okay.
So, there's a big buyer buying, you
know, 1400, 1100, 2,100, 3,900.
And we go up, we make new highs, right?
We we go up, we break out from 31, we
break out at 12, get all the way up.
Right now, we're trading, you know,
where are we trading? Four, four and a
half at new highs here. So, you know, as
an orderflow trader, you need to be able
to pivot
from bullish to bearish back to bullish,
right? I mean, that that's what you're
going to do as a trader. You can't get
married into a position. But again, you
know, sort of the tip off was this thin
volume here, eight
We rally up to new highs, come back in.
Now you see the support coming in here.
15,000 13,000 on the bid, right? These
are your your heaviest volumes in the
bars coming in on the bid side
supporting that market. And again, what
looked bearish turned out there was no
follow through, right? Something can
look bearish in the order flow,
but if there's no follow through, it's
not going to move, right? It has to move
based off of what you're seeing in the
market. Okay? Other traders have to sit
up and say, you know what, yeah, let's
let's start selling this. If they're not
coming in and starting to selling it,
instead they're being aggressive and
they're buying it, right, with the stack
buying imbalance, then you know that
maybe the selling that you saw here is
probably people taking profits from
earlier cuz remember we just rallied up,
you know, at 6:00 in the morning from
the lows all the way up to new highs at
8:30.
So, you know, in 2 and 1/2 hours, we
went from our low at 18 1.5 all the way
up to 31.
Strong buying on the way up. So maybe
some of these buyers are finally taking
you know their profits up here. Then it
comes back with strong aggressive buying
into new highs. So you know that's how
you know orderflow can help you when the
markets get you know VIX jumps up to
very high levels and you know if you're
struggling in your normal markets go to
I say slower moving markets but markets
that are much more liquid. um you know
markets are much more liquid. They tend
to
have smoother moves in the sense that
it's not jagged. What would you rather
trade something methodical like this
where you know it's easy to understand
what you're seeing in the order flow or
you know this market where you know some
of these bars okay you know this bar
goes from you know basically 2 and 3/4
all the way up to 14 1/2. So again,
about 12 points. You know, some of these
smaller bars, you know, this one here on
the low at 1 and a4,
this red [clears throat] bar where we
made this new low, you know, goes from
one and a quarter all the way up to six
and a half. So that's, you know, what is
that? 5 1/2 points. This current bar
that we're in from two all the way up to
11, 12, you know, that's a 10point move
in a bar. And yeah, if you're positioned
correctly, that's great.
When you get a bar that's moving 10
points in a minute, there's going to be
some inherent volatility in that bar, it
could stop you out really quick before
the market runs
in your direction. Okay? So again, you
know, just because the market picks up
in volatility doesn't mean that you got
to stay away from the market. There's
other plenty of other markets out there
for you to trade. Again, so
thanks for watching this video. I sort
of jumped around a lot. Um I didn't
script it out. But I just wanted to get
a video out there for you guys to sort
of understand that, you know, there's
plenty of other markets out there for
you to trade. Um, you don't have to be
locked in and struggle with the markets
that you normally trade because
volatility picks up. All right, so
thanks for watching this guys and I'll
catch you on the next video.